he's Joe Manganiello here on the show
what do you think of that introduction
show hi rich I'll take it thanks man
I think they react I think that's
accurate
um so how do I know you're big penguins
fan but this this has got to be so this
has got to be like hog heaven for you
sure yeah well especially because I want
I mean I could be doing a show with with
a bunch of jokes where I just make a sad
face all night long so thank God for me
they won but ya know it's huge I'm a
huge hockey fan and huge penguins fan
and been very vocal and my fandom over
the past couple of years and so when the
NHL reached out and asked me to host I
mean come on that's a no-brainer that's
amazing how does Crosby compare
size-wise to you
Crosby uh he is I've gots eyes on him
but I'm like more like a Lindros type of
hockey hockey sized player okay but but
man sit I mean you you watch the series
or you know any of the playoffs I mean
that guy moves like nobody else on the
ice he's such an unbelievable player and
when it all comes down to it this week
Joe I mean who's coming outside of the
current players that you've heard of
that you're excited to be with a lot of
great Mario will be there Wayne Gretzky
I believe Mark Messier is going to be
there sital be there because you won the
goals competition and obviously his
current player but you know they're
celebrating 100 years of the 100 great
NHL's NHL players of all time so there's
going to be a whole whole smattering of
great there where does Mario rank for
Pittsburgh
all-time athletes Joe Wright and I know
we've had this conversation before I
rank and we've had some great Steelers
great pirates obviously there's this
Clemente to Stargell and and all of the
the Steel Curtain Steelers and even a
lot of the currents and troy polamalu
who's my favorite Steeler of all time
but when you talk about what Mario
Lemieux has done
for not only the franchise that he
played for but then transitioning to
become an owner he was owed 30 million
dollars by the team he turned that into
a percentage of the team and then wound
up keeping them from moving I mean what
other sports team out there the greatest
player of all time then became the owner
of and saved the team from moving and
then went on to win more cups I'm in or
Championships it's just it's unheard of
there isn't there isn't a story like
that out I mean in any town no for
anybody I mean you could sit here and
wonder about teams that have been saved
by uh by private dollars or teams that
eventually were run you know I mean
Elway runs the Broncos but the Broncos
were not in danger of leaving town and
he doesn't own the Broncos yeah I mean
it really there's there's no story like
that and then the fact that he survived
cancer on top short what about cancer
and then the the day of his final cancer
treatment chartered a jet took a nap and
then got on that plane and flew to
Philadelphia and had a goal in and
assist that evening it's it's just
unheard of he's such an incredible and
he's such an incredible guy he's such a
charitable and wonderful guy I met him
the first time I hosted the Pittsburgh
Children's Hospital 125th anniversary
gala I serve on the board for the
Children's Hospital as does he and
that's where I met him the first time
and he's just an incredible
philanthropist and a real you know
man-about-town he loves Pittsburgh and
we've adopted him and in my opinion
there is no greater Pittsburgh sports
icon than Mary LMU there's no one that's
done more for the city Joe Manganiello
actor big-time penguin fan and host of
the NHL Awards that's coming up later on
this week on NBCSN June 21st at the
t-mobile Arena in Vegas joining us from
Vegas right now how in the world is the
expansion draft working into this are
you the host of that - are you
announcing the picks a la Bettman
Goodell that sort of thing what are you
doing here can be blended in
there's their little B and integration
to it but it is exciting in in a way
that you know you want to see who-who
ones of getting selected and who your
team is losing they can only protect so
many people so the Golden Knights are
going to be picking up a lot of those
players so you know it's going to be a
great night of all the greats welcoming
in the newest crop so if let's just say
you are announcing a golden night pick
and it's a penguin you don't want to
lose will you switch it up a la
moonlight and lala land and just
announce whoever the hell you want
notice it will that happen is that a
possibility yeah yeah there's a huge
possibility of whoever I don't like on
the opposing team so I'm going to give
those guys away there you go yeah look
at that you know but in all seriousness
though is like are you giving away like
the Lady Byng and I don't know if you've
seen the runner show yet Vesna trophy
you're going to give away the Calder and
then there's another pick for the golden
it's the way it works in from you're
going to be split up I think it's split
up into sections as far as how the
team's landed or how they have a placed
in the end and then we'll read off the
blocks of who Golden Knights have
selected from each one of those teams
okay and is there a Billy Crystal like a
music number that you're opening up the
show with oh yeah what do you got
because I'm trying to distance myself
from the whole Magic Mike thing and
seeing as how much especially I've just
opened there in Vegas right yeah I'm
gonna yeah maybe we'll do some spoken
word but I don't know about the thing in
advance okay
so there'll be a spoken word Todd
monologue or something like that that's
what a whispered and Alec Baldwin joy
come on now you can't get Channing Tatum
out there right on on on Thursday on
Wednesday night right you and him
Soderbergh can whip something up in two
seconds flat and that's the way we open
up the NHL Awards a show de Burgh likes
to leave those lights on the truck so
you know I don't know I don't know I'm
not sure he likes the film with natural
lighting yes okay yeah but look all I
can say is this going to be a big
surprises okay to knit and and since
we're in Vegas set the over-under on
number of catfish jokes oh well
listen I've already pre-recorded
so there's definitely kept getting all
right Joe say hi to everybody for me and
we'll chat soon come in in Los Angeles
but let's hang out soon will do thanks
rich always you got it let's Joe
Manganiello the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country
and audience if you like that video be
sure to download our app don't have any
memory on your phone let's start to
delete some of those slo-mo videos you
have and you know which ones I'm talking
about